[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harowitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy the Trump Administration recently
released a list of Terror attacks that
said were unreported or underreported by
The Establishment media and the parents
of two of the victims of one of the
listed attacks were enraged in August
2016 a Muslim named smil ayad screaming
Allahu Akbar stabbed two people to death
in an Australian hostile Not only was
this not terrorism we're supposed to
believe but president Trump is a
terrible person for including it on his
list of Terror attacks Rosie aif the
mother of 21-year-old victim Mia aif
Chung wrote an open letter to Trump in
which she declared my daughter's death
will not be used to further this insane
persecution of innocent people The
Washington Post added helpfully that yes
SM aad had had yelled Allahu Akbar
during the attack but he had also
rambled incoherently stabbed a dog and
was apparently infatuated with her
daughter in her open letter to President
Trump ath added I have spoken to friends
of Mia and other Backpackers who worked
long days in the fields with ayad and
none of them ever saw him put down a
prayer mat Salat or prayer is the second
of five pillars of Islam and calls for
five daily rituals of ablution prayer
and prostration an Islamic
fundamentalist by definition must
respect the five pillars of Islam it
would be very hard to imagine someone
managing to perform this ritual five
times a day in the close confines of
Home hill hosel without Witnesses any
fool can shout allahuakbar as they
commit a crime Les Jackson the father of
the other victim Tom Jackson agreed and
excoriated Trump for not doing his
homework he said I'm pretty sure he and
his advisers know full well or could
very easily verify that Tom and Mia died
not as the result of an act of Terror
but rather through the actions of a
disturbed individual of course that
doesn't suit his agenda Jackson added he
said Allahu Akbar it's a bit like me
saying I'm Jesus Christ in reality it is
nothing whatsoever like saying I'm Jesus
Christ Allahu Akbar is often
mistranslated in the western media as
God is great but the actual meaning is
Allah is greater meaning Allah is
greater than your God or any other thing
it is the aggressive declaration that
Allah and Islam are dominant over every
other form of government religion law or
ethic which is why Islamic jihadists in
the midst of killing infidels so often
shout it one primary purpose of shouting
is to strike Terror in the hearts of the
enemies of Allah as the Quran commands
at chapter
8:60 nonetheless according to the
Townsville bulletin Queensland police
the Australian federal police and the
joint count counterterrorism unit
investigated any links between ayad and
radical organiz ations and they did not
find any evidence of
radicalization now this is an example of
the prevailing denial and political
correctness that hamstrings our approach
to Jihad Terror ayad wasn't carrying an
Isis membership card he wasn't going to
mosque he wasn't praying five times a
day so therefore they say there's no
evidence of radicalization and president
Trump is both stupid and evil to
classify these murders as Terror the
problem here is that the Paradigm that
aith Jackson and even the Queensland
police the Australian federal police and
the joint counterterrorism unit are
working from is false and erroneous a
Muslim who never goes to mosque does not
pray and is not otherwise observant may
be carrying around a large load of guilt
he may know that an easy way to offset
all of his sinful Deeds is to perform an
act of jihad and the Quran guarantees
Paradise to Those Who Kill and are
killed for Allah that's in chapter 9:
111 so in this case SM Yad May indeed
have been a bit unbalanced and
unhealthily fixated on Mia alif Chung
and troubled by that or any number of
other things and he may have conceived
of an easy way to get back into Allah's
good graces by killing her and Tom
Jackson that he stabbed a dog would even
be in keeping with this for Muhammad the
prophet of Islam ordered that dogs be
killed a Hadith says it was narrated
that Abdullah Ian Umar said the
messenger of Allah used to order that
dogs be killed and I went through Medina
and we did not spare any dog but we
killed it to such an extent that we
would even kill the dog of a woman
belonging to the desert
people all this doesn't make aads
murders acts of terrorism akin to 911 or
Fort Hood or San Bernardino he probably
didn't think of himself as acting to
advance the cause of the Muslim umah or
as an operative of al-Qaeda or the
Islamic State but authorities aren't
even aware they aren't even considering
the possibility of killing as an act of
personal experation within Islam they
should be president Trump is not to
blame here the faulty and partial
understanding of Islam universally
accepted by government law enforcement
and the establishment media is I'm
Robert Spencer
[Music]